[Musique]
dans les livres d'histoire on oublie
souvent que louis xiii fut un monarque
très important il est parfois cité
uniquement en référence à d'autres
souverains en tant que fils d'henri iv
roi bourbon cher au coeur des français
ou que père du roi soleil louis xiv on
le connaît bien sûr également grâce aux
trois mousquetaires d'alexandre dumas
mais quand on étudie son règne d'un peu
plus près on s'aperçoit que l'histoire
est injuste en se focalisant sur son
brillant ministre
le cardinal de richelieu et en laissant
dans l'ombre ce roi souvent décrié et si
mal jugé
le règne de louis xiii est un règne
d'autorité
c'est un c'est un homme qui va lancer
cette longue période de d'absolutisme
quand on examine la figure de ce
souverain énigmatique on découvre une
saga fascinante et pleine de violence
c'est un enfant qu'on a forcé à grandir
très vite qui a dû se montrer très tôt
raisonnable et un homme qui a fait
montre d'un dévouement total à son pays
sa personnalité unique a été forgé par
une enfance difficile et troubler son
père henri iv qui l'adorent et poignardé
à mort alors qu'il n'a que 8 ans le
voilà soudain propulsé rois de france
il a 14 ans lorsqu'on le mari à une
princesse étrangère et il n'en a pas 16
lorsqu'ils trouvent le courage de mettre
un terme à la régence qu'exerce sa mère
espérant ainsi sauver la monarchie
miné par la corruption ce véritable coup
de force lui vaudra son surnom de louis
le juste ayant adhéré dès son plus jeune
âge à un ensemble de principes stricts
le jeune roi définit les objectifs de
son royaume en fonction de ces critères
moraux et durant toute sa vie il
s'efforcera de faire les choses de façon
juste
ces règles éthiques seront mises à mal
par le divorce entre le peuple et
l'élite
pendant des années il sera écartelée
entre la loyauté envers sa mère et celle
qu'il doit à son royaume
mais quand il aura trouvé en la personne
du cardinal de richelieu un homme à la
fidélité sans concession et qui
partagent sa vision de la france et son
sens des valeurs
louis xiii en fera son premier ministre
et défendra jusqu'à la fin ce grand
homme d'état
si impopulaires pour richelieu la
rigueur de son souverain prouve la
nécessité de mener une politique subtil
la volonté de justice du premier
ministre est empreinte de la plus grande
sévérité
mais elle s'inscrit dans une stratégie
destinée à rendre plus efficace
l'administration du pays à renforcer
l'autorité de la couronne et assurer la
gloire de la france
malheureusement si louis xiii parvient à
réaliser ses objectifs
c'est au détriment de sa vie personnelle
son action politique va transformer la
france mais son attachement aux
principes moraux qui le gouvernent le
conduira à sacrifier sa santé
le 27 septembre ce 101
mais pour la première fois en cinquante
huit ans au sein du couple régnant un
dauphin comme toute naissance d'un fils
de roi c'est évidemment un événement
d'autant plus qu' henri iv avait d'abord
été mariée une première fois
et lorsqu'il à ce fils ou c'est que la
dynastie est assuré et du coup il ait
plus de problème pour le royaume de
france
son père henri iv fou de joie de monde
qu'on ouvre les portes de la chambre
puis il s'écrit avec fierté cet enfant
vous appartient à tous la naissance d'un
fils stabilise évidemment l'accession
des bourbons et au trône de france dès
ce jour le futur louis xiii et
surveillant en permanence son médecin et
sa gouvernante observe attentivement
chaque étape de sa vie lui prête une
attention toute particulière et relate
chaque détail de son état de santé dans
leurs journaux
louis subira de nombreux traitements
invasifs durant toute sa vie privée de
la tendresse maternelle dont il a besoin
souvent battus et de santé fragile c'est
un enfant solitaire mélancolique et
craintif mais parfois aussi méfiant
irritable autun est têtue ses traits de
caractère se retrouveront dans la
manière dont il règnera plus tard et
c'est surtout un enfant qui est très
antagoniste à la fois il peut se montrer
sociable par moments et de temps en
temps et bien il se retire pendant
pendant des jours et des jours et on ne
retrouve plus le petit gamin que non la
laissait auparavant
alors ça va donner forcément un roi
antagonistes si l'enfant était déjà le
roi le sera aussi
louis xiii est un homme qui est à la
fois qui peut se montrer simple qui peut
se montrer gentil mais qui est
caractériel et autoritaire
en tant que dauphin il développe un sens
aigu de l'autorité qu'il applique à ses
frères et soeurs bâtard avant de pouvoir
l'exercer pleinement en tant que roi
mais il est difficile pour lui d'être à
la fois le dauphin un fils obéissant et
le sujet du roi
il se crée alors en lui une tension
entre la volonté de suivre sa voie et la
nécessité d'être éduqué en vue des ces
obligations futures à 7 ans la
discipline sévère que lui a imposé son
père l'a amené à améliorer son
comportement mais il a acquis en même
temps l'habitude de réprimer ses
sentiments tout en étant très sensibles
à toute remise en question de son
autorité c'est un enfant timide sans
doute un peu écrasée par la personnalité
de son père qu'il adore et qui de
surcroît un inconvénient il est bègue et
il a une certaine difficulté à
s'affirmer
il sait qu'il doit acquérir toutes les
qualités d'un roi il a rapidement fait
siennes les vertus morales de louis 9
le saint louis du moyen-âge les
questions qui agitent son règne sont
celles de la morale et de la lutte pour
la justice
les historiens s'accordent à dire que le
caractère déterminé de louis xiii a pu
s'exprimer dans une personnalité animé
de principes forts
en tant que roi il pense qu'il a avant
tout un devoir envers son pays
[Musique]
en retour comme on le lui a enseigné ces
sujets lui doivent loyauté et obéissance
[Musique]
le 14 mai 16 110 le petit louis rentrer
au palais des tuileries après une
promenade
quand on lui dit que la reine veut le
voir au louvre il monta les escaliers en
courant parmi le tumulte des voix et des
bruits de parts et se dirigea vers le
cabinet de son père un corps couvert de
sang était allongé sur le lit
sa mère se détacha du groupe ampleur et
se précipita vers lui le roi est mort le
roi est mort une main se posa sur
l'épaule de louis une voix d'homme
solennel est sévère
selva au dessus du tumulte votre majesté
me pardonne les rois ne meurt pas en
france voilà le roi vivant à huit ans et
demi il devient louis xiii marie de
médicis assurera la régence jusqu'à ce
qu'il atteigne la majorité c'est à dire
à l'époque ses 13 ans
cinq mois plus tard il est couronné en
la cathédrale de reims et dans notre
dame de reims retentissent clairon
hautbois trompette et hambourg
il grandit sous les yeux de la cour à
laquelle il offre un visage courageux
mais en vérité c'est une triste période
pour lui privé de l'amour de son père
mal à l'aise face à une mer rigide et
autoritaire ils redoutent les
responsabilités qui l'attendent
l'assassinât d'henri iv est liée à la
méfiance qui perdure dans la population
quant à sa fidélité au catholicisme au
cours des guerres de religion henri de
bourbon qui avait été le chef des
huguenots a accepté de se convertir à la
religion d'état pour assurer la
pérennité du trône et le retour de la
paix dans le pays
quand il s'est allié à ses voisins
protestants pour mettre un frein aux
visées expansionnistes de l'espagne et
de l'autriche
il a suscité les foudres de la ligue
catholique malgré son immense popularité
ces alliances avec les protestants et
ses projets de guerre contre l'autriche
lui ont valu de nombreux ennemis à la
mort de son époux marie de médicis
catholique convaincu au immédiatement
des mesures favorables à l'espagne est
hostile aux protestants la reine au
pouvoir interrompre sitôt la politique
offensive comme né henri iv à sa mort
pour revenir à l'alliance traditionnelle
catholique avec l'espagne elle annule
les projets de guerre d'henri iv contre
l'autriche et accélère les démarches en
vue de conclure une double alliance
matrimoniale avec la famille royale
d'espagne
il s'agit d'unir louis xiii anne
d'autriche et la soeur du jeune roi de
france
elisabeth au futur philippe iv d'espagne
on pense que la régente conspire à
ensuite pour saper l'avenir royal de son
fils en particulier en l'empêchant de
développer ses connaissances
intellectuelles henri iv avait apporté
la paix mais il n'avait pas réussi à
créer l'unité dans le royaume malgré les
avancées des rois précédent la structure
politique de la nation est encore
essentiellement féodal on voit
régulièrement des factions issu de la
noblesse conspiré contre le roi lever
des armées privées et s'allier à des
puissances étrangères
au cours du règne de louis xiii le
royaume va être troublée par des
complots fomentés par des membres de sa
propre famille élargie
le premier est dirigé par le prince de
condé
henri de bourbon qui avec les autres
grands n'accepte pas d'avoir été exclue
du conseil et fait pression pour que
soit mené des réformes qui favoriserait
les nobles louis n'est pas prêt à renier
dans la discorde politique
pour son 13e anniversaire il annonce
officiellement qu'il est désormais
majeur mais ajoute comme on le lui a
demandé qu'il souhaite que sa mère
continue à exercer la régence marie de
médicis calme la rébellion en acceptant
de convoquer les états généraux
ce sont des assemblées exceptionnelle
qui réunissent le clergé et la noblesse
et le tiers état où la bourgeoisie de
bonneville mais chaque ordre ceux réunis
séparément
les états généraux sont convoqués en
1614 à l'aube de la majorité droit à roy
est majeur à l'âge de 13 ans il est né
le rased et le 27 septembre 1601 et
surtout à ce moment là marie de médicis
ne tient plus du tout sa noblesse et
elle a besoin de rassembler les états
généraux pour affirmer le pouvoir du roi
et chacun son point de vue sur la
meilleure manière de rétablir l'ordre
dans le royaume si les longs débats ont
permis de compléter l'éducation du jeune
roi il sort bien peu de choses des états
généraux de 16 114
cette assemblée est la dernière avant
celle qui aura lieu en 1789 en pleine
révolution
elle marque les débuts d'un jeune évêque
le futur cardinal de richelieu qui prend
la parole en tant que représentants du
clergé
ces dispositions intellectuelles attire
l'attention de marie de médicis qui le
nomme grand aumônier auprès de la future
reine anne d'autriche louis épouse anne
d'autriche l'année suivante ils ont tous
de 14 ans le mariage de louis xiii
s'explique par part par un traité qui a
été qui a été signé au mois d'août 1612
avec l'espagne et donc lui 13 est obligé
de se marier contre son gré et
d'ailleurs en novembre 1615 louis
accompli son devoir le mariage est
consommé
mais cette première expérience forcer le
traumatise il craindra d'avoir avec elle
d'autres rapports intimes
après cette nuit de noce désastreuse il
ne voit que rarement son épouse et évite
pendant quatre ans de rester seul avec
elle
louis conserve à l'âge adulte le
comportement hérité de son enfance il
réprime ses sentiments et se méfie de
son propre jugement
son insécurité le place dans une
situation de conflit intérieur permanent
il a besoin d'avoir quelqu'un sur qui
s'appuyer qui lui apporte un soutien
effectif et en même temps il a un désir
forcené d'indépendance
c'est un homme qui n'aime pas les femmes
ça c'est ça c'est tout à fait clair
c'est un homme qui a du mal à avoir une
relation avec une femme et c'est un
homme qui va aussi mettre de son
caractère dans ses relations avec les
hommes il se plaît beaucoup plus à à
être avec des ce qu'on appelait des
compagnons du compagnon de chasse il
était beaucoup plus à l'aise n'avait
plus honte de bégayer alors qu'il était
assez mal à l'aise avec les femmes
on parle souvent la misogynie de de
louis xiii et très régulièrement il
essayé d'écarter les femmes de soi de
versailles plus tard soit de différentes
parties de chasse qui pouvait faire et
il a toujours été liée à plusieurs
favoris ça et aylwin ça a été trois rats
ça a été ça marc saint simon le père du
mémorialiste et il a toujours besoin
certainement d'avoir un mentor pour
avancer son amitié avec charles
fauconnier du roi est la première d'une
longue série de relations affectives
qu'il entretiendra avec des hommes louis
à 12 ans et charles 35
cette intimité avec un homme d'âge mûr
apporte au jeune roi l'attention les
soins et les conseils dont ils manquent
tant ainsi que la confiance qui va lui
permettre d'agir de son propre chef
rejetant la sexualité
le jeune roi trouve une diversion en
s'adonnant à des activités physiques qu
il les puise
il partage le goût de son père pour la
guerre et la chasse à 19 ans il est lui
même un passionné de chasse et un soldat
aguerri mais sa principale préoccupation
devient très vite son devoir de monarque
il renonce à ses parties de chasse pour
assister à toutes les séances du conseil
le jeune roi arrive à la jouant jeune
homme fidèle à ses principes
il va s'engager à être le père de son
peuple puissant et juste
les mariages entre la famille royale et
les habsbourg ne rencontre pas
l'approbation générale
une autre cause de mécontentement né des
faveurs que marie de médicis accorda
deux étrangers cupide sa dame de
compagnie
leonora galigaï et son mari concino
concini la régente s'appuient de plus en
plus sur consigne
cet italien est très impopulaire non
seulement c'est un étranger mais il a
obtenu plus de pouvoir et de richesse
qu'aucun oble français le conseiller
d'état inde marie de médicis donc il va
développer véritablement 7,7 cet élan ce
mouvement pro italien à la cour
c'est lui aussi qui va essayer
d'influencer marié de médicis en
sous-main en souterrain contre lui 13
de plus on lui prête un comportement
arrogant et ostentatoire la colère
contre la régence de marie de médicis
excite le mécontentement d'un nombre
croissant de sujets et en 16 116 éclater
une seconde rébellion menée par condé
est appuyé par les huguenots les condés
et les factions de consigny se bat pour
accéder au pouvoir
louis se retrouve dans une position
ambiguë il est officiellement le chef de
l'état mais il est toujours sous la
tutelle de sa mère
finalement l'abus de pouvoir flagrant de
consignes et son comportements
licencieux choc à ce point la morale que
louis se trouve forcé de s'opposer à sa
mère il devient définitivement l'ouïe le
juste et justifie son attitude par son
désir de rester fidèle à ses principes
la réaction de louis xiii elle a été
celle du timide qui veut s'imposer qui
finalement excédé a ordonné l'assassinât
de concini pour parvenir ni même à
prendre le pouvoir
avec l'assentiment du roi ses partisans
fomente un assassinat le 24 avril 16 117
consigny devenue maréchale tombent dans
une embuscade en arrivant au louvre et
il est poignardée à mort les juges du
parlement de paris accuse son épouse de
sorcellerie et la condamne à être
décapité après ce coup la reine mère est
obligé de s'exiler au château de blois à
15 ans louis devient roi de france
dans les faits autant que par le titre
après avoir conseillé louis xiii dans sa
prise de pouvoir en 116 117 le duc de
luynes figure paternelle l'aide
également à trouver le bonheur dans son
mariage il pousse littéralement le jeune
homme dans le lit de son épouse et on
ferme à double tour les deux tourtereaux
louis parvient à surmonter sa peur et
après cette nuit les deux jeunes gens
âgés alors de 17 ans vont vivre une
véritable lune de miel transformer en
amoureux attentionné louis sera heureux
pendant près de quatre ans et tout le
monde espère voir bientôt naître des
enfants royaux mais en 16 122 leroy
apprend que son épouse a fait une
deuxième fausse couche
elle a fait une chute alors qu'elle
traversait le louvre en courant avec une
de ses compagnes n'ayant aucun héritier
pour assurer sa ligne et il est du
devoir de louis de poursuivre leur
relation charnelle mais la passion et la
tension qu'il éprouvait pour son épouse
sont remplacés maintenant par la
méfiance leurs sentiments et une
distance affectueuse la relation va être
restera toujours très difficile jusqu'à
la fin il n'y aura pas de rapports
rapprochés entre louis xiii et sa femme
à la fois avec cet aspect physique qui
atteint lui 13
ils n'aiment pas les femmes ne veut pas
en entendre parler fait les enfants
parce qu'il faut les faire parce que
c'est son devoir mais ça ne devait pas
être une masse partie de plaisir entre
entre louis xiii et sa femme
les réformes effectuées par henri iv
avait permis de réduire la corruption
mais la régence de marie de médicis ont
ramené ce fléau premier plan avec
l'anarchie
en réponse louis emprunt de justice
morale début de son règne en s'attaquant
aux vices jurés blasphémer voler tuer et
se battre en duel deviennent des crimes
punissables
ils touchent ainsi surtout la noblesse
le duel est le moyen de défendre ce
qu'un noble a de plus précieux son
honneur en france 2010 et listes avaient
été tués en un an
cette tradition est est illégale mais
tolérée par les gouvernements précédents
le noble la noblesse ne peut pas
travailler ne doit pas travailler de ses
mains on tolère de temps en temps
quelques quelques menus travaux dans la
marine 1
quand on peut éventuellement être
officier dans la marine quand on est
noble et surtout on se bat on se bat
pour l'image de sa famille louis xiii
interdisant les duels il est domestique
complètement sa noblesse
en tout cas il la tient véritablement
d'une main de fer pour louise juste
toute infraction à la loi est un affront
à son autorité royale
il aborde ensuite la question religieuse
c'est un fervent catholique mais il
partage les idées de son père sur la
tolérance religieuse consignées dans le
célèbre édit de nantes de 15 198
ils s'opposent cependant à certaines
dispositions de lady en sanctionnant les
villes huguenote qui avait été autorisé
à édifier des fortifications et à agir
comme un état dans l'état
louis exige la fidélité de tous ces
sujets ceux qui le défient sont punis et
certains même très sévèrement
t c'est une période très difficile c'est
une période aussi où louis xiii essaie
d'asseoir un peu plus encore son
autorité il n'y arrivera pas d'ailleurs
en totalité
parce qu'il ya une ville comme
montpellier par exemple qui va résister
à louis xiii et louis xiii va devoir
d'ailleurs signé ils ont un acte de paix
avec la ville de montpellier laisser
quelques huguenots dans cette ville bien
précises un traité de paix permet aux
gones au de conserver les villes
fortifiées de montpellier de la rochelle
mais ils en perdent 80 autres le roi
doit également s'attaquer au désordre
qui règne au sein de sa propre famille
en 719 marie parvient à s'évader du
château de blois où elle était assignée
à résidence louée est mortifiée quand il
apprend que sa mère une femme qui n'est
plus tout jeune et bien lourde s'est
glissé en plein hiver par une fenêtre
pour effectuer une descente périlleuse
sur une échelle tremblante et tout cela
afin de rejoindre des rebelles armés
contre lui un conflit brefs mais
violents éclatent entre la mère et son
fils louis relève bravement le défi on
16 120 les troupes de marie de médicis
ont vaincu et elle est obligée de faire
la paix il rappelle le cardinal de
richelieu pour qu'il serve de médiateur
maintenant que son pouvoir est établie
il autorise marie de médicis à revenir à
paris et lui accorde une place au
conseil en 722
les habsbourg d'espagne et d'autriche
ont agrandi leur territoire depuis sept
ans que louis règne en personne lorsque
les habsbourg d'autriche s'engage dans
une escarmouche avec les princes
protestants en 16 118 louis c'est que
leur succès éventuel risque d'accroître
leur pouvoir déjà considérable en europe
en france les opinions sont divisés
certains sont pros catholique d'autres
pros français louis et résiste au devoir
moral qui lui commanderait d'aidé à la
mission religieuse des habsbourg
il choisit de suivre la voie de son père
en défendant les intérêts séculaire de
la france et en limitant le pouvoir de
ses rivaux la france entre dans ce
conflit que l'on appellera plus tard la
guerre de trente ans de manière
indirecte
alors ce l'attitude de louis xiii c'est
simplement de desserrer cet étau qui
enserre le royaume lempire à l'est
l'espagne au sud et l'italie au milieu
qui est très largement possession des
habsbourgs son problème ça va être
justement de trouver des alliances et de
propulser la guerre dans l' empire pour
faire pièce à cette puissance et après
des débuts assez catastrophique 736 est
l'année de corby la france est envahie
par les troupes impériales petit à petit
louis xiii lui même prend la tête de la
contre offensive et on arrive en fin de
la guerre de trente ans c'est la france
qui va être la première puissance
européenne
elle soutient en secret les ennemis
protestants des habsbourgs malgré sa
réputation de roi très catholique sa
politique étrangère l'éloignent des
dévots qui voit toute attaque contre les
habsbourg comme une attaque contre la
religion pas piste
c'est avec une certaine réticence que
louis xiii suit les conseils de sa mère
et propose au cardinal de richelieu de
rejoindre le conseil royal en 16 124
tout d'abord méfiant le roi prend
progressivement conscience du génie de
ce serviteur de l'état et de sa loyauté
indéfectible envers la couronne de
france
armand jean du plessis est né en 15 285
dans une famille de la petite noblesse
il est le cinquième fils d'une fratrie
de six enfants
après avoir été ordonné prêtre il a été
nommé par henri iv évêque de luçon
petite ville de vendée en 16 116 marie
de médicis en fait le secrétaire d'état
pour la guerre et les affaires
étrangères
[Musique]
leroy s'accommode du caractère solitaire
de son ministre et lui permet de
travailler depuis sa résidence de reuil
l'actuel oreilles malmaison louis xiii
réside souvent dans sa demeure d'enfance
tout proche de saint germain il
communique par l'intermédiaire d'un
messager
richelieu supervise la construction de
son propre palais à paris le palais
cardinal qu'on appellera par la suite le
palais royal
cette collaboration entre le roi et son
ministre est caractérisée par un respect
mutuel il travaille dans le cadre de ce
qu'on a appelé le ministère ya et le
ministère ya c'est un couple sans
plaisir 8,13 a compris que richelieu
avait une intelligence qui lui étaient
nécessaires
il l'a tolérée auprès de lui il l'a
soutenu
il l'a maintenu au pouvoir un richelieu
est mort dans son lit donc le roi l'a
toujours soutenu mais on ne peut pas
dire qu'il y ait eu une grande affinité
entre les deux personnages
c'est une alliance politique qui
témoignent d'ailleurs de l'intelligence
et de la complémentarité des deux
personnages richelieu ne peut sait qu'il
ne peut pas accéder au pouvoir sans le
roi et le roi sait qu'il ne peut pas
exercer son pouvoir sans les capacités
de richelieu et ça donne un couple
finalement assez solide
louis apporte son courage et ses
principes moraux et richelieu son génie
politique et militaire
ils partagent tous deux des idées
conservatrices et le premier ministre
prend très rapidement des mesures
drastiques pour moraliser la vie de la
nation
le mépris flagrant des nobles pour les
lois témoignait de l'effondrement de
l'ordre social avec le soutien de
richelieu le duel est dorénavant
considéré comme un crime capital contre
son gré louis xiii fait exécuter de
nombreux représentants de la noblesse
qui ont enfreint la loi ou conspirer
contre lui les juges qui s'opposent à
ces sanctions d'une extrême sévérité
sont emprisonnés ou envoyés en exil
louis xiii est un homme qui veut tenir
sa noblesse dans sa main elle le fera
pas autant que louis xiv parce que louis
xiv créera versailles pour cela mais lui
13 va ne va pas hésiter en tout cas à
écraser dans l'oeuf les complots des
nobles à brûler les châteaux quand il le
faut ces exécutions choc la cour le
peuple y voient la main du premier
ministre et de là naît la légende d'un
roi aux services de son ministre
sous richelieu des réformes sont mises
en place pour limiter les trop grands
privilèges accordés à l'aristocratie en
16 126 il supprime la charge de
connétable de france et ordonne la
destruction des châteaux forts
à l'exception de ce qui serait
nécessaire à la défense contre les
envahisseurs
ainsi des pouilles t-il les princes les
ducs et des nobles de moindre rang de
moyens de défense dont il pourrait
accuser contre les armées royales lors
d'une rébellion alors louis xiii et
paroisse qui veut être obéi et donc avec
si l'on peut dire la complicité de
richelieu qui en quelque sorte son bras
armé il va réduire à l'obéissance les
nobles et le premier d'entre eux c'est
son frère gaston d'orléans agents de
toutes les conspirations du règne mais
le roi ne va jamais faiblir va déployer
une autorité sans faille
richelieu s'attirant ainsi les foudres
de la noblesse
les dissensions religieuses constituent
un autre obstacle à la centralisation du
pouvoir
le roi a détruit l'indépendance des
villes fortifiées mais les aigus nos
dispose encore d'une force militaire
importante et sont toujours en état de
rébellion
quand le roi d'angleterre charles le
premier déclare la guerre à la france
pour aider le camp protestant richelieu
donne l'ordre d'assiéger la forteresse
huguenote de la rochelle sur la côte
atlantique
les calvinistes thien thanh ans et ce
livre finalement en 16 128 en 529
ils seront vaincus et massacrés à privas
puis alès il n'y a plus d'état dans
l'état par l'édit de grâce de nîmes
les réformés sont amnistiés ils
obtiennent la liberté de culte mais on
leur enlève leurs privilèges politiques
place de sûretés et assemblées
politiques avant même l'accession de
richelieu au pouvoir la majeure partie
de l'europe étaient engagés dans ce qui
sera la guerre de trente ans le cardinal
poursuit la politique de louis xiii
il subventionne en secret les princes
protestants néerlandais suédois et demi
des habsbourg
d'autre part l'espagne convoitent des
territoires du nord de l'italie
cette région est un élément stratégique
majeur dans l'équilibré des pouvoirs en
europe
elle sert de lien entre les habsbourgs
du saint-empire romain germanique et
l'espagne si les armées impériales
parvenait à s'emparer du nord de
l'italie
l'existence même de la france serait
menacée puisque elle se retrouverait
encerclé par des territoires ennemis les
problèmes politiques de la deuxième
moitié du règne de louis xiii trouvent
leurs racines dans les guerres
extérieures et la recherche de fonds
pour les financer pour dissimuler le
fait que la france est partie en guerre
contre d'autres monarques catholique
louis fait le geste religieux le plus
symbolique de son règne il place le
royaume de france sous la protection de
la vierge et instaure les procession du
15 août durant lesquelles les sujets
doivent prier dieu et la vierge pour les
heureux succès du roi en 16 130
le cardinal est de plus en plus menacé
par son ancien protectrice marie de
médicis lui devient hostile quand elle
voit qu'il ne cherche pas à s'allier à
la coalition austro espagnol
la journée du 11 novembre 16 130
c'est le jour où marie de médicis par
qui richelieu est arrivé au pouvoir se
rend compte que sa créature richelieu
mène auprès du roi une politique qui
n'est plus la politique catholique
d'alliance avec l'espagne qu'elle
souhaitait mais que richelieu pousse le
roi a attaqué l'an pire elle va donc
provoquer une entrevue avec son fils
louis xiii où elle va demander la tête
de richelieu elle convie le roi et son
ministre chez elle au palais du
luxembourg
en les accueillant elle se lance dans
une diatribe contre richelieu et exige
de lui qu'il choisisse entre elle et le
cardinal le roi demande à richelieu de
partir si bien que sa mère est convaincu
d'avoir obtenu le renvoi de son ennemi
celui-ci persuadé que sa vie est en
danger s'apprête à fuir
mais marie de médicis ne tarde pas être
informée que c'est elle qui doit quitter
la cour louis xiii dispute avec sa mère
dispute violente toute la noblesse pense
et croit que il va y avoir quelque chose
qui va se passer on va remercier marie
de médicis et c'est chose faite
louis force sa mère à l'exil pour la
seconde fois
elles sont fut aux pays bas espagnols
tandis que le frère du roi gaston
d'orléans se réfugier à la cour du duc
charles iv de lorraine où il continuera
a complété contre son frère son succès
louis ne reverra jamais sa mère après la
journée des dupes richelieu accélère la
réalisation de ses objectifs politiques
avec l'appui du roi il réprime toute
activité rebelles et intervient de plus
en plus dans le processus judiciaire
les exécutions deviennent monnaie
courante en 16 135 louis xiii âgé
maintenant de 33 ans déclare la guerre à
philippe iv d'espagne
les besoins financiers qui en découle
provoque une hausse des impôts
alors ce n'est pas à proprement parler
une réforme institutionnelle mais c'est
plutôt un tour de vis spectaculaire
l'entrée de la france en guerre se
manifeste pour le royaume par une
augmentation absolument un fabuleuse des
impôts jamais on n'avait vu une
augmentation de ce type et il faut bien
voir que face à l'espagne la situation
de la france est totalement différente
l'espagne elle tire ses ressources de
l'or et de l'argent de ses colonies la
france d'hier ses ressources des impôts
qu'elles prélèvent sur ces populations
alors bien sûr la france et plus peuplé
est un royaume riche mais il y a une
limite et cette limite
elle va se manifester pendant que la
france va être en guerre à l'extérieur
elle va aussi être en guerre à
l'intérieur puisque les populations vont
se révolter contre ce tour de vis fiscal
qui leur est insupportable
la taille prélèvements devenu permanent
depuis la guerre de cent ans frappe
surtout les paysans en 739 la population
s'oppose au contrôle à la guerre aux
impôts et une vague de révoltes rend
impossible la collecte de l'impôt la
couronne en blâme les responsables
locaux
mais ils ne peuvent être congédiés selon
la règle coutumière il faut changer les
institutions mais avec délicatesse en
particulier quand il s'agit de revenir
sur d'anciens privilège pour remédier à
l'absence de contrôle richelieu décide
que des intendants seront nommés par le
gouvernement pour représenter
directement la couronne
ces changements administratifs simple
système hiérarchique traditionnelle et
provoque des protestations dans toutes
les classes de la société richelieu
devient à la fois high écrin il est
considéré comme étant à l'origine de la
pauvreté et de toutes les souffrances du
peuple
on va avoir à richelieu qui a envie de
remettre la france au travail
1 ce n'est pas un discours moderne le
disque ans que l'on entend aujourd'hui
un petit peu partout sur les télévisions
c'est un discours qui date d'il y a
quelques années et richelieu par exemple
va limiter la construction du monastère
il va demander aux gens de haut à son
peuple de travailler plus pas pour
gagner plus mais ça va être en fait une
véritablement une volonté de louis xiii
mettre la france au top au travail à
travers cette politique car richelieu
qui est d'ailleurs tout à fait novatrice
très peu ont compris que ces réformes
vont permettre à la france de retrouver
son rang parmi les grandes puissances et
la rendre totalement indépendante de l'
empire des habsbourg
après dix années de collaboration le roi
et son premier ministre ont réussi à
recentrer le pouvoir entre leurs mains
la personnalité et le style de louis
xiii se sont construits en réaction par
rapport au passé
il est profondément religieux sa cour
est d'une grande sobriété l'atmosphère
austère qui règne se démarque de la
débauche qui fleurissaient autant de son
père louis ne montre que peu d'intérêt
pour le domaine culturel
le devoir seul l'obligent à autoriser sa
mère son frère et le cardinal richelieu
à agir au mécène ses projets de
construction reflète de simples besoins
et non un désir de léguer à la postérité
un style architectural qui porterait son
nom en 16 924 louer fait bâtir un
modeste rendez vous de chasse dans le
village de versailles ovale de gally
donc pour sa première chasse de louis
xiii est emmené à versailles il en garde
un très bon souvenir
finalement il y fait édifier en 16 123
124 un premier château qui est tellement
ridicule qu'on le moc tout le monde les
gones à picot la case qui se fait
fabriquer pour pour son divertissement
et il le fait détruire pour un nouveau
château ans à 131 5 134 qui est le point
de départ du château actuel qui sera
agrandie par son fils ou 14 et donc
c'est vraiment un lieu de retraite pour
lui c'est à dire c'est là où il vient
avec ses compagnons de chasse comme tous
les rois bourbon louis xiii adore la
chasse et il vient ici avec ses
compagnons alors la reine anne
d'autriche à des appartements mais elle
ne dort jamais le roi fait toujours en
sorte de la ramener sur le chemin de
saint germain à paris ce qui me dit que
les femmes gagnent tout si elles
viennent à versailles et c'est ici qu'il
vient pleurer aussi par exemple quand
avec son amour platonique un quizz de là
ça y est le modèle de la fayette parce
que décide de se retirer au couvent en
il vient pleurer ici dans ce petit
château de versailles
donc c'est vraiment un lieu de retraite
pour priver pour lui 13 la brique rouge
la pierre doré la petite retraite sur
deux étages avec son toit en tuiles
dardoise bleus seront plus tard
transformé par louis xiv pour devenir le
fameux château de versailles à la
splendeur inégalée louis xiii laisse son
empreinte indirectement dans la culture
française en renforçant les mouvements
religieux de son époque le renouveau
d'un catholicisme qui tentent des
réformes pour ramener ses fidèles vers
leur religion d'origine est sans doute
une conséquence de la grande piété du
monarque en architecture le centre de
paris reste médiévale mais le xviie
siècle est le siècle du baroque un style
italien prodigue en ellipse courbes et
ondulations
on le retrouve dans les monuments les
théâtres les décorations et l'art de
l'illusion optique de cette époque
sous louis xiii paris n'embrasse pas ce
style avec le même enthousiasme que les
grandes villes européennes
cette retenue reflète la sobriété et
l'austérité du règne ainsi qu'un certain
scepticisme
pour tous ceux qui semblent excessifs ou
original le seul témoignage
architectural de louis xiii est sans
doute la première église construite pour
les jésuites il fait don de terrain à
l'église saint louis qui porte alors le
nom du roi louis 9 et qui est devenu
aujourd'hui l'église saint paul et saint
louis cet édifice dans pearl influences
baroques par une retenue toute classique
une caractéristique que l'on retrouvera
tout au long du règne de louis le juste
[Musique]
contrairement au roi son premier
ministre considère les arts comme un
moyen d'impressionner et par conséquent
de gouverner richelieu joue donc un rôle
actif dans ce domaine en se construisant
un patrimoine est également une fortune
personnelle
il constitue l'une des plus grandes
collections d'art d'europe et une
collection de sculptures romaine antique
sans égale en france alors louis xiii
n'est pas un grand culture si on peut
dire louis xiii est certes un musicien
estimable il a un joli coup de crayon
mais celui qui assume la politique de
promotion culturelle de la monarchie
c'est richelieu et richelieu va nous
léguer non seulement son château de
richelieu qu'on ne voit plus aujourd'hui
mais qui était quelque chose d'assez
incroyable c'était énorme et châteaux
qui assurait la gloire du roi et la
gloire du ministre puisque là ne pouvait
pas lui ne pouvait pas aller sans
l'autre
eca richelieu tout était double mais il
va aussi nous les des toute son action
en faveur des lettres avec c'est bien
connu la création de l'académie
française mais aussi tout ce théâtre
dans richelieu était on le sait en
amoureux avec cette salle qu'il avait
fait construire dans son palais cardinal
et ses pièces auxquelles on sait qu'ils
avaient plaisir à mettre la main pour
leur rédaction
grâce à ses efforts en tant que mécène
le règne de louis xiii et célèbre par la
création de l'académie française
l'oeuvre de saint-vincent-de-paul dans
le domaine de la religion
rené descartes en philosophie et pierre
corneille en littérature parmi les
artistes de la cour on trouve rubens
auquel marie de médicis commandes à un
cycle entièrement consacré à sa gloire
ainsi que des portraits de louis xiii et
d'anne d'autriche france pour bus le
jeune pénit également des portraits
d'henri iv et de louis xiii
il a saisi le caractère soupçonneux
sérieux et incertain du jeune roi
louis xiii continue à agir en roi
guerrier au cours des dernières années
de son règne et à se battre contre les
habsbourgs mais ce combat inlassable
pour protéger la france et repoussé les
frontières à l'est vers l'alsace et au
nord vers les pays bas espagnols aggrave
encore son état de santé
la distance s'est accrue entre le roi et
son épouse au fil des ans mais ils
connaissent de brefs instants de
réconciliation c'est ainsi que naîtra
enfin un garçon en cev 138 après 18 ans
de mariage la naissance du dauphin est
considéré par la population comme un
miracle on baptise louis l'enfant qui
est promis à devenir un demi dieu sous
le nom de louis xiv richelieu tombe
gravement malade en 16 142 et le roi
reste à son côté jusqu'à la fin le
premier ministre désigne le cardinal
mazarin ancien envoyé pontificale comme
son successeur et décède le 4 décembre
16 140 2 cinq mois plus tard le roi le
suit dans la mort il disparaît à l'âge
de 41 ans le jour du 33e anniversaire de
la mort de son père il est enterré avec
les rois de france dans la basilique de
saint denis
le cardinal de richelieu lui est inhumée
dans la chapelle de la sorbonne
c'est son fils alors âgé de 4 ans qui
succède à louis le juste sa mère à
d'autriche devient régente seconde et
par mazarin elle supprime volontairement
de l'éducation du petit dauphin toute
mention sur la façon de gouverner de son
mari y compris son surnom louis xiv et
son époque jugeront que richelieu avait
gouverné la france est son droit et que
louis avait été à bord mais qu'il avait
été induit en erreur les opposants et
les sceptiques mettent en doute le rôle
politique de louis xiii après
l'avènement de richelieu d'autres
affirment que les positions du roi en
matière de politique intérieure et
extérieure était déjà fermement établie
en 16 124 ce dont on se souvient à
propos de son règne
c'est le coup d'arrêt qu'il donna à la
corruption à la violence et à la
criminalité
les paye nos qui prospérait au sein même
de la nation a été détruit la puissance
financière et administrative de la
france s'est développée et la domination
des habsbourgs est en déclin
cela n'aurait pas pu être accompli sans
la présence de richelieu aux commandes
du pays
mais toutes ces réalisations sont liés à
la vision que louis xiii avait du monde
et à l'ensemble de ses convictions
les registres de richelieu d'après 724
montre qu'il informer régulièrement le
roi des questions nationales et
étrangères et qu'il prenait ses ordres
près de lui en dernier ressort
lors de l'ascension de louis xiii en 16
110 la règle absolue n'était pas
incontournable la noblesse représentait
encore une immense force bien décidé à
conserver son statut au sein de
l'organisation sociale et politique qui
datait alors du moyen-âge
à sa mort en 16 143 le pouvoir royal a
été consolidée et celui de la noblesse
affaibli la france est devenue un état
fort et centralisé
louis xiii commencent finalement un peu
le règne de louis xiv
c'est à dire qu'il va il va
véritablement posé les fondations de
l'autorité royale et ses fondations vont
rester des dizaines et des dizaines
d'années
et si l'on peut faire véritablement une
synthèse du règne de louis xiii a été
véritablement de calmer la noblesse
d'asseoir l'autorité royale et surtout
de l'avoir en main richelieu est l'un
des fondateurs de l'autocratie dynastie
il a brisé la puissance de la noblesse
féodale et des protestants en nommant
des intendants et il à consolider
l'autorité de la couronne sur le pays
même s'il manquait de charisme et de
courage politique
louis xiii deuxième roi bourbon a joué
un rôle particulier aussi bien avant
qu'après l'arrivée de richelieu au
pouvoir soldats et catholique austère il
a consacré sa vie à consolider le
royaume
cherchant la justice et protégeant ses
sujets les décisions prises pendant son
règne ont eu d'immenses répercussions et
ont contribué à façonner la nouvelle ère
dans laquelle entraîne le pays
ces changements auraient été moins
important sans son association avec le
cardinal de richelieu les deux premiers
objectifs du premier ministre
centralisation du pouvoir en france et
opposition aux habsbourg était des
moyens d'obtenir le résultat final
le cardinal est souvent présenté comme
un homme froid et cruel à cause des
contraintes qu'il a imposées à la
population française mais en réalité
c'était un homme profondément religieux
qui a tort ou à raison estimant que ces
pertes humaines étaient nécessaires à la
gloire de la france louis xiii et
dépeint parfois comme un insensible les
historiens eux le décrivent comme un
homme doté d'une grande force intérieure
qui l'obligeait à mettre de côté ses
sentiments sa célèbre phrase je ne serai
pas roi si j'avais les sentiments des
particuliers
laisse penser qu'il ne se permettait pas
de ressentir les souffrances de son
peuple il avait décidé depuis longtemps
que cela serait trop douloureux
les obligations de la monarchie en paix
cher le roi de trouver le bonheur dans
sa vie personnelle mais le siècle de
louis xiii sur remarquable par les
transformations radicales qu'il sut
opérer certains très antipathique de sa
personnalité et son manque de confiance
en lui ont relégué louis xiii au second
plan de l'histoire de france
on se souvient de lui comme le plus pâle
des souverains de la lignée des bourbons
mais le soutien infaillible dont il
gratifia richelieu la construction d'un
état nation et sa politique étrangère
belliqueuse sont le préambule nécessaire
à l'avènement du roi soleil qui
deviendra le monarque le plus puissant
d'europe à la tête de la nation la plus
puissante de son époque